number 32 Cooper
FL and he's from the DMV area and a lot
of those people are hoping he goes back
to Maryland there you go right off the
tip welcome
home in the
country quick Outlets Ace Flag now
Cooper jams it
homeon Haw he's really skilled really
knows how to play
flag for three swish now this is more
aggressive than I've seen him he's he's
looking for his individual off Tigers
thought they were in there good and then
it kind of flipped in the last 24 hours
went to a different breed of cat he did
round the screen from Newell here's s
working on two Defenders doesn't matter
so when they switch on that ball screen
it put gerak on flag he did a nice job
guarding him a few moments ago that time
flag took his time got to his left hand
kak rejected by flag let's go get some
uh support for that argument with a lot
of people here in the state of M but
it's I I understand the other look out
oh Cooper
flag this or if this is just a change up
to start the half oh if Cooper flag can
bury shots like that they may not be
able to stay in zone for very long yeah
we talked about it with his height he
was playing the post yeah and as we said
you could you can make an argument he's
the two guard in this
lineup Nick NE slams it
[Applause]
home that Nick
Lewis given switched up on him Harper
rejected by flag another block for super
quarter rights to newel got gerak in the
air gerak played it as well as he could
but there's flag for the Fallout well
not only Cooper but the other nine 10
kids on that team oh another block for
Cooper here's a screen from Queen oh
great move by flag
hello and Cooper and Ace Flag back home
and a standing ovation for Cooper maybe
he'll play another game in Maine Adam
mention potentially two can play up here
and of course yeah he'll play
tomorrow